esta multitud se congregó frente a la
casa blanca en washington para mostrar
su apoyo a ucrania condenar la invasión
rusa y para generar conciencia una
iniciativa que se extendió por todo eeuu
nuestra nación se está desgarrando
nuestras familias se esconden en
refugios antibombas ucrania necesita
ayuda somos nuestra propia cultura
nuestra identidad nuestro pueblo y
necesitamos ayuda para seguir vivos
estatua de la libertad se vistió con los
colores de ucrania mientras que una
bandera gigante se desplegó en times
square nueva york es la ciudad de
estadounidense con mayor población
ucraniana y donde se ubica el barrio
conocido como la pequeña ucrania aquí la
ong razón que significa juntos en
ucraniano está trabajando para reunir
suministros que ayuden a salvar vidas y
ha creado un corredor desde eeuu hasta
ucrania para entregarlos
[Música]
los sonidos de este coro tradicional
ucraniano sonaron en las salas de todo
el país el icónico programa saturday
night live rindió homenaje la leyenda
del pop estadounidense madonna se
pronunció en instagram publicando un
vídeo de uno de sus seguidores contra la
invasión de putin el cantante
estadounidense lenny kravitz de padre
ucraniano tuiteó su apoyo mientras que
la pareja de hollywood blake lively y
ryan reynolds anunciaron que recaudarán
hasta un millón de dólares en donaciones
para ayudar a los refugiados ucranianos
por su parte la ópera del met de nueva
york anunció que dejara de trabajar con
artistas que apoyen al presidente ruso
vladimir putin un mensaje y llevado al
mismo escenario mientras que el elenco
de don carlos entonaba el himno nacional
ucraniano antes de su presentación